The sacrifice of the mother is
exemplified profoundly by Michelangelo's
sculpture.
That Pie Ada,
Mary is Contemplating Her son crucified
in ruins,
so that's his body after he's being
crucified.
It's her fault.
It was through her.
He entered the great drama of being.
So what's the meaning of this sculpture?
It's a great sculpture.
It's just an absolutely unbelievable
sculpture.
You just can't believe that someone
could exist who could make something up.
Of course it wasn't the only thing
Michelangelo made,
right?
It wasn't like that's it.
It was something he just tossed off in a
couple of months while he was doing
other unbelievable things,
but you know,
it's,
it's an.
It's an object of contemplation,
which is why it's integrate cathedral,
integrate city.
It's an object of contemplation and the
idea is something like,
what,
what?
What's the role of a mother if she's
awake.
I had a client come to see me a while
back,
not very long ago,
woman in about who's about 30 and trying
to make decisions about her life.
She was pretty career oriented and so I
asked her about,
although maybe having a bit of trouble
with their career,
I've seen this many,
many times,
so this is an amalgam.
This is a story that's an amalgam and I
talked to her about the other elements
of your life.
It's like,
Whoa,
you know,
there's only five things you do in life,
so you've got your career down,
you know,
what do you do outside of your career
that's meaningful and engaging.
How are things going with your family?
Could be your family of origin,
your siblings,
whatever.
Do you have an intimate relationship and
like what's your plan for your own
family?
And apart from those five things,
there's sort of something like get some
exercise now and then don't eat too
badly and try to stay away from the
drugs.
You know,
that,
that kind of the crime that kind of lays
out life.
And if you miss any of those five things
or if you do any of those other things
wrong,
then you're in trouble and you can get
away with missing a couple of them.
But not all of them,
you know.
And she said something along the lines
of,
well,
I'm not sure I should bring a child into
this world.
And I thought,
Oh God,
Christ,
you've got to come up with something
better than that.
Such a bloody cliche,
which is what I told her.
I said,
you know,
he must've thought that up when you were
16.
It's like,
really?
That's your,
that you can't do any better.
This was a very,
very smart woman.
It's like creating your unique.
You can't do any better than that.
It's like,
yes,
obviously this is a veil of tears and a,
you know,
a well of suffering and all of that.
If you asked 30 people who are wondering
about having children,
why they're wondering,
20 of them will say that.
And so that tells you how original it
is.
It's not original at all.
It's not a thought.
It's like this little.
It's like a,
it's like a,
it's a meme or something that lives in
your mind.
It's not a thought and it's certainly
not something.
It's certainly not something that you
should just take it face value and say,
oh,
well I'm not having a family.
Then it's like,
no,
no.
You kind of look at that and you
criticize it a little bit.
It's like,
well,
the pop,
the.
It's the other one.
That's the other one that's very common.
There's too many people on the planet
already.
It's like,
I really don't like that statement.
just who are you going to ask to leave?
Just how are you going to get them to
leave?
You know?
It's a serious question and who says
there's too many people?
What the Hell's wrong with people?
Anyways?
Sorry,
we're running around ruining the planet.
Yeah,
so like I think it was the club of Rome
who,
who prophesied by the way that there
would be so many people on the planet by
the year 2000,
that there would be widespread
starvation and they were completely and
utterly wrong about that and I think it
was the club of Rome who either compared
us to a virus or a cancer on the face of
the planet.
It's like,
oh,
really?
That's what you think about people a,
aren't you something?
Isn't that something to think about?
Human beings,
viruses and cancer.
What do you do with viruses and cancer?
Invite them in and make them at home.
It's like,
no,
he tried to eradicate them.
If you've got a bloody well,
watch your metaphors folks,
because it isn't clear that you come up
with them or that they run you,
so you better watch him.
So anyways,
Mary and Mary's the great mother,
right?
That she's the mother.
That's what Mary is.
Whether she existed or not is not the
point.
She exists,
at least as a hyper reality.
She exists as the mother.
Well,
what's the sacrifice of the mother?
that's easy.
If you're a mother and you,
if you're a mother who's worth her salt,
you offer your son to be destroyed by
the world.
That's what you do.
I mean,
that's what's going to happen,
right?
He's gonna be born and he's going to
suffer.
He's gonna have his trouble in life.
He's going to have his illnesses.
He's going to face his failures and
catastrophes and he's going to die.
That's what's going to happen.
And if you're awake,
you know that,
and then you say,
well,
perhaps he will live in a way that will
justify that,
and then you try to have that happen and
that's what makes you worthy of a statue
like that.
But still the sacrifice of the mother.
Is it right to bring a baby into this
terrible world?
Well,
every woman asked yourself that
question.
Some say no.
And they have the reasons Mary answers
yes.
Voluntarily.
Mary is the archetype of the woman who
answers yes to life voluntarily.
That's what that image means.
And not because she's blind,
she knows what's going to happen.
And so she's the archetipal
representation of the woman who says yes
to life knowing full well what
[inaudible] life is not naive,
not someone who got pregnant in the
backseat of the 1957 Chevy,
you know,
in one,
in a,
one night of,
of,
of half drunk idiocy.
Not that,
but consciously,
consciously knowing what's to come and
then also allows it to happen.
Because that's another thing that's a
testament to the courage of mothers.
And My mother was good at this.
My mother's a very agreeable person too,
agreeable for her own good,
but that's what happens if you're
agreeable because you're too agreeable
if for your own good.
That's the definition of agreeable.
And so she's a nice person and still is.
Luckily she's still alive and we've had
a very good relationship and I have
always been able to make her laugh,
which is,
which is a good thing.
And,
but she was tough cookie.
That woman,
you know,
if,
uh,
remember once she came across,
I was out playing in this spec baseball
diamond,
little diamond in the empty lot.
Really in this little town I grew up in.
I was about 10 and she walked by.
I was there with a bunch of my friends
and I was about to have a fistfight with
this little tough kid that I hung around
with.
And there were half girls on the team
and the fistfight had some relationship
to status maneuvering,
you know,
in relationship to that.
Anyways,
we're going to have a fight.
And my mum walked by,
she took a look and I could see from her
demeanor that she knew exactly what was
about to happen and she looked for a
second and then she walked by and I
thought,
Whoa,
good work mom.
No kidding.
Hey.
It's like last bloody thing I needed at
that moment was for her to come charge
it up and say,
you boys aren't planning to have a
fight,
are you?
It's like,
well yeah mom,
where we're actually planning to have a
fight and now that you came and
intervened.
I actually lost before the God damn
thing even started.
So two thumbs up for mum.
She was also the person that said
because I had some trouble with my dad
when I was a kid,
adolescent,
he had some trouble with me.
So you know,
it was 50 slash 50.
That's for now,
it's probably 70 slash 30 with me on the
70 end of that being the trouble.
And anyways,
I left home when I was about 17 and she
said something really interesting when I
left home.
She said it was too good at home.
You'd never leave.
I thought,
hey mom,
that's pretty good,
you know,
for,
for an agreeable person,
you've got a real spine man.
So that was pretty good.
So.
So you know,
mother that says this,
the mother is the person who also says,
get out there,
take your God damn lumps because you're
tough enough so that you can handle it.
She doesn't say you just stayed down
there in your bedroom bruiting away
because the world is unfair and treating
you badly and your suffering is too
much.
She says,
yeah,
there's a lot of suffering out there,
but you're a hell of a lot tougher than
you think you are.
So.